[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
tony joins us now tony good to see you
again uh i you should know that we get a
christmas card from you every year on on
the show so uh i don't know if you know
that but the foundation sends us a
christmas card and we got one of your
skateboards in here as well in the man
cave so thank you hey it's my pleasure i
want to be represented there you know
i'm just i just keep trying to inch my
way back in
if i would have told you 30 years ago
skateboarding is going to be in the
olympics you would have said what
um yeah right sure okay
would you have wanted
would you have wanted skateboarding in
the olympics back then
um
sure yeah i was never against it i i
obviously skateboarding gave me so much
as as a youth and
and shaped my identity and my way of
looking at things but at the same time i
wasn't coveting it i wasn't like this is
our thing and no one else can see it i
was always wondering why it wasn't more
popular and so to have had it in the
olympics back then would have been a
great boost i think and um hey i would
have loved to join the fun too because i
didn't know how it felt like the x games
when they came along it felt like that
was the anti-olympics but did you know
there were certain sports that maybe
didn't want to be in mainstream did you
sure you understand that but i think
that there's a population of skaters
that feel that way absolutely um and
ones that do coveted and don't and don't
want that and and did start skating
because it was their
antithesis to team sports
um i just never felt that way uh but
i do think the x games what i loved
about x games is they let us be
our sort of irreverent selves
and so sometimes the the rules were
pushed in terms of letting someone go
past time or letting someone go way off
script and jump off the course or do
something that wasn't in the confines of
the uh competitive uh
book
and we knew going to the olympics that
wouldn't fly
what did you see in tokyo
uh i saw some of the best skating i i
saw a uh a whole new generation of
skaters that are at the top of the game
and
i saw after the fact a lot more interest
in skateboarding in terms of
international embracing of it
how would you have done at 15
um
i think i would have done pretty well
i think i turned pro when i was 14.
that's the thing that there's a whole
there's a whole uh
sort of misperception that all these
like what happened all these kids are
young that's been happening forever i
mean i turned pro when i was 14. i won
my first world championships when i was
15. nigel houston was considered the
best street skater when he was 13. so
it's not a great surprise i didn't think
it would be across the entire podium
but uh it just shows that they they not
only they had the skills they had a
strategy
what did you do like is there something
about being young that makes you
even better i don't know if it's being
fearless but what is it about being 14
or 15 years of age and being great at
skateboarding as opposed to if you were
25
uh i think the resilience that you can
bounce back from from big falls maybe a
little easier and in terms of the park
event which is more of the the ball
transition skating uh that
it's it's
the size of that is not the the usual
size like what i skate a vert ramp vert
ramp is about 13 to 14 feet tall
those ramps are closer to 10 and if your
size is is suitable for that you can
actually utilize it better
and so the younger kids have a slight
advantage in terms of how they can go
much higher because they can ball up
and get up there
if this was a game of operation where we
got to see your body how many broken
bones would we we have in that that game
of operate do we have a hot spot on your
body that uh
a little bit more surgery
um
well it's certain knees
uh with surgeries but nothing broken on
my knees uh luckily i broke my elbow i
broke my pelvis um and uh dislocated my
fingers
um last year that's why these are so fat
okay but at what point do you not get on
that skate you're you're going to be 53
or you turn 53 i think i am 53 okay
so at what point do you go i don't know
if i can get on the the skateboard here
i
i think i don't know if i'll ever reach
that point i may reach a point where i
don't want to do it in public
so there's probably a moment where i
think you know what
maybe today's not the day to go show off
well i was wondering how old is too old
to get on a skateboard but you're saying
as long as nobody sees it then i can get
on it the rest of my life
if an elderly man steps on a skateboard
and there's no one around to see it
doesn't actually happen
did you attend high school
yes yeah
like all the way through oh you did
yeah
but you're touring in public school yeah
but here in san diego uh it was a little
tricky in my junior senior year because
i i was requested or required to travel
for my job as a skater
and um
i tried to make up my work like my
grades definitely suffered in my senior
year
what are you making at age 14 when you
turn pro
uh you're gunning for a hundred dollars
first place prize money in the
professional competition that was it
that was it okay but how who decides or
how do you declare i'm going pro
you just that means you can qualify for
uh the prize money
yes well i i had reached the top of the
amateur rankings
and so at the next event uh
i was filling out the entry form for the
event and there was one box that said
amateur and there's one box that said
pro and so i ticked the pro box
and that was it there were there were no
you know birds were not singing there
was not a big celebration
um it was more like well now you're in
the big leagues and you're gonna be
skating against guys that are four to
five years older than you who gave you
the nickname birdman
um
someone on espn i'm gonna i'm gonna
probably guess it was selema masakayla
okay and you're okay with birdman
i mean i've just come to embrace it it's
okay i mean it could be much worse hey
when i was a kid
tony hawk rhymed with bonnie cox so um
birdman is
much more flattering
that's a tough childhood tone
[Laughter]
was that bullying i i guess
they just called it being picked on yeah
but you people i love that they go up to
you and they go you look like tony hawk
and
every day your response is
um i've heard that
my last response is i i've heard that
quite a bit but you're the first today
and also who else you're mistaken for
um
as of lately i i got i got lance
armstrong
and then i got tom brady believe it or
not i mean hey whoa whatever it takes
whoa um but i think it's just more that
it was it was in their mind it was like
oh that's an athlete t
tony tom tom brady that's it tom brady
i don't think it was about the looks
if uh you had to get out of the house
with one piece of memorabilia
what would you take
oh wow
um
that is that that is a difficult
question
um
i do have the skateboard that i did the
first 900 on from x games 1999.
and if i'm gonna go memorabilia it's
probably that one where is that right
now
uh it is actually at my office where my
ramp is
but um
let's just say if there's a fire at the
office that's what i'm taking
tell me about uh what's going to go on
in utah the utah state fairgrounds there
well like i said ver uh the half pipe
vert discipline is something that that
was not in the olympics but i think is
something that still is thriving and and
it's a different style of skating
because it's more aerial based so it's
more of the of the big jump the stuff
you saw at the x games
and so i'm you know on the heels of of
the olympic success i'm trying to bring
back the whole vert discipline and we're
taking my ramp that you've probably seen
me skate indoors um
at my office we're taking the whole
thing to salt lake city and putting it
up and it's a free public event some of
the best vert writers we've got a
legends uh skate session
on the 27th um with people like steve
caballero christian osoye and myself
mike frazier andy mcdonald
so i'm excited i feel like
uh i've been trying to push for
something like this for the last few
years obviously it got shelved over the
last year and a half for uh and now
we're going for it
it's great to talk to you again tony we
appreciate your time and uh have fun in
utah thank you
yeah thanks john that's uh tony hawk and
uh
that's seton seton's geeking out like
he's a girl watching the beatles perform
at shea stadium there